meanwhile joe biden pushing radical
immigration policy as well his
immigration policy is pretty obvious
open the borders and let everybody come
this has some pretty dire side effects
by the way
but even new york times reporters at
this point are acknowledging that
migrants are showing up on mass on the
southern border
specifically because of joe biden i was
actually just at the border and
some of the families i spoke to who had
recently arrived did say that another
reason
is the transition to a new
administration they perceive
president biden who campaigned on a more
compassionate approach to the border
than his predecessor
as potentially being more lenient at the
border
so um yes i mean that's perfectly
obvious by the way the unintended side
effect of this
is that wait for it wait for it wait for
it joe biden is keeping kids in cages
now i'm old enough to remember because
again i'm more than three years old i'm
old enough to remember
when having to house kids in temporary
detainment facilities
was considered nazi-esque right donald
trump was a nazi this was nazi germany
america
well now we know that kids are being hap
they are being held in cages
literal cages okay the new york times
reporting a surge in migrant children
detained at border is straining shelters
quote the number of unaccompanied
migrant children detained along the
southern border has tripled
in the last two weeks to more than 30 3
filling facilities akin to jails i love
how they say this right
facilities akin to jails what let me
call a facility akin to a jail
what is is there is there could we look
to the thesaurus please
facility akin to a jail
oh you're talking about kids in cages
that's what you mean that's what you
mean new york times
as the biden administration struggles to
find room for them in shelters according
to documents obtained by the new york
times
more than 1 360 of the children have
been detained
beyond the 72 hours permitted by law
before a child must be transferred to a
shelter according to one of the
documents
dated march 5th you mean we have over a
thousand children
who are being held in cages in defiance
of federal law because you don't have
the resources
you know who else did this had a little
mustache spoke german
yep yep you know what i'm talking about
the figures highlight the growing
pressure on president biden to address
the increased number of people trying to
cross the border in the belief
he will be more welcoming to them than
former president donald j trump was yes
even the new york times is acknowledging
that this is all about joe biden saying
we are going to let everybody in
when you tell everybody that you're
going to let them in and just give them
asylum and they're going to release them
into the interior
what the hell do you think is going to
happen these are radical policies
policy shifts guys we're going back to
the welfare policies of the 1960s we're
going back to the immigration
policies essentially of of
of amnesty like full-scale amnesty come
to the border and we will let you in
and we are going to the gender power
going to gender policies that are so
radical
that they would have been beyond the
radical feminist of the 1990s that is
that is where we have gone and all of
this is being done as a non
as a non-functional member of the of the
upper echelon of american politics
stumbles around into objects
and chases after his dog naked that is
what we are as a society that is what we
have become
a non-sentient person is now running
administration
he he ain't running it right it runs
itself
it runs itself because all we do every
four years is just elect
the team of administrators who are going
to dictate our lives meanwhile other
transformational changes
there the democrats are pushing forward
hr one we've discussed this on the
program before this is a radical shift
how voting is going to be done in the
country now remember
according to the democrats there was no
voter fraud and no voter irregularity in
the last election cycle
it was the cleanest election in american
history according to democrats
i know that's why it resulted in a joe
biden win because it was such a clean
election
well now democrats are claiming we need
a massive overhaul
of every voting system in the united
states which is weird since if you guys
are so concerned about voter fraud and
regularity
why exactly are you doing this hr one is
not merely
a vote broadening procedure hr 1 is a
complete overthrow of the federalist
structure with regard to voting
and is in an attempt it is an attempt to
backfill american voting law
so as to make it easier for people to
commit voter fraud and regularity that's
what hr one is
so what is in hr one what is in this
this massive
new voting bill that democrats are
pushing forward according to national
review
it would be an understatement to
describe hr one as a radical assault on
american democracy federalism and free
speech
is actually several radical left-wing
wishlists stuffed into a single 791-page
sausage casing it would override
hundreds of state laws governing the
orderly conduct of elections
federalized control of voting and
elections to a degree without precedent
in american history
and two centuries of state power to draw
congressional districts turn the federal
elections commission into a partisan
weapon and massively burden political
speech against the government
while offering government handouts to
congressional campaigns and campus
activists merely to describe the village
to damn it
and describing it is a herculean task in
itself states have long experienced
running elections different states have
taken different approaches
the federal government traditionally
intervened only to prevent serious
abuses of voting rights
hr 1 would upend that balance for no
good reason wrecking carefully refined
state regimes for securing the vote
it also throws out much of the work of
federal election laws passed with
extensive bipartisan support in 1993
and 2002. the first target is wiping out
state laws that allow voters to be
checked against a pre-existing
list of registrations hr 1 mandates
states provide same-day registration and
allow people to change their name and
address on the rules at the polling
place on election day
then forbid states from treating their
votes as provisional ballots that can be
checked later
which is a recipe for massive voter
fraud it mandates online registration
without adequate safeguards against
hackers and mandates automatic
automated registration of people who
apply for unemployment medicaid
obamacare in college or who are coming
out of prison
right so basically anybody who's
government dependent is going to be
automatically registered to vote which
you can see why democrats aren't pushing
this the bill's authors expect this to
register non-citizens they create a safe
harbor against prosecution of
non-citizens who report they have been
erroneously registered
state voter id laws are banned they are
replaced simply by a sworn voter
statement
the dramatic expansion of mail-in voting
during covet is enshrined permanently in
federal law
states are banned from the most
elementary security methods for mail-in
ballots they must provide a ballot to
everyone
without asking for id and may not
require notarization or witness to
signatures
states are compelled to permit ballot
harvesting so long as the harvesters are
not paid per ballot
so democrats can just pay per hour and
just go pick a bunch of democrat ballots
curbside voting ballot drop boxes 15
days early voting are mandated
nationwide
the bill micromanages the location and
hours of polling stations early voting
locations
and drop boxes states must accept voter
registrations
from 16 year olds even though they can't
vote before turning 18.
the bill shifts the job of sending up
young voters to the federal government
which will pay to teach 12th graders how
to register
create a campus vote coordinator
position on college campuses and award
grants to colleges for demonstrated
excellence
in registering students to vote
restrictions on felon voting felon
voting in federal elections
are overridden and h.r 1 takes the
drawing of congressional districts out
of the hands
of elected state legislatures who have
done the job since the founding and
turns them over to quote unquote
independent commissions
it also counts inmates as residents of
their last address even if they are
serving
a life sentence and there are crackdowns
on political speech
one provision could be read to bar
corporations from political activity if
they have a single foreign shareholder
new disclosure rules would treat huge
amounts of speech and advertising as if
there were campaign contributions
this would require donors to say the
aarp to be identified as supporters of
any candidate if the aarp demands the
candidate keep a promise to protect
social security
501c4s would be required to disclose
their owners
i mean it's a mess it's a complete mess
and this is what's being pushed forward
by the biden administration so moderate
so much unity you can see it happening
now if you get the feeling that these
folks just want to control your life in
pretty much every way
and then rig the system so that they
always win elections through ballot
harvesting
and through unverified ballots and make
it less
less trustworthy okay remember i am not
one of the people who thought that voter
fraud and regularity decided the 2020
election
in fact i spoke out against that idea i
didn't think the evidence was provided
i was willing to hear evidence if it was
provided there's not a lot of evidence
provided
okay i'm not one of the people who was
saying that i don't trust results of
elections
i'm saying i will not trust the results
of future elections if they are done
under the auspices of this garbage bill
it's gonna be very difficult to trust
elections when you are literally just
registering voters on the same day
as they change their names and addresses
and those ballots are not counted as
provisionals
if that alone is enough to undermine
voter integrity
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button